lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
hablar sobre la diferencia entre una
afirmación normativa y una afirmación
positiva verán que estas palabras a
veces se usan en el contexto de la
economía y a veces en el contexto de la
filosofía una afirmación normativa es
aquella que se basa en una opinión quizá
es una cuestión ética es algo que
alguien piensa que debe ser así una
afirmación positiva es algo que no
necesariamente es cierto pero es algo
que puede ponerse a prueba ahora veremos
un grupo de afirmaciones relacionadas
con la economía y las clasificaremos
como afirmaciones normativas o
afirmaciones positivas las afirmaciones
normativas son cosas que son opiniones o
cuestiones éticas o morales y las
afirmaciones positivas son cosas que
pueden comprobarse veamos la primera
afirmación
y pagar a personas que no trabajan
cuando pueden trabajar no es justo y
está mal
esta es claramente una opinión por lo
que es una afirmación normativa pues no
podemos comprobar si esto es justo o
está mal es la opinión de cada quien
sobre lo que es justo o está mal veamos
esta otra afirmación programas como la
asistencia social reducen el incentivo
para que la gente trabaje podríamos
pensar que es normativa porque parece
una opinión pero puede ser probada se
puede crear un programa de asistencia
social a menor escala en algún lugar y
compararla con un lugar similar que no
tenga programas de asistencia social
para ver si tiene algún impacto en el
incentivo para trabajar se aplican
encuestas y se observa cuántas personas
trabajan en una situación y en la otra
podría ser una afirmación verdadera o
una afirmación falsa pero de cualquier
manera puede comprobarse así que esta es
una afirmación positiva por lo que la
ponemos en esta categoría veamos otra
afirmación
y aumentar los impuestos a los ricos
para pagar los programas de gobierno
hace crecer la economía es una
afirmación normativa o positiva
nuevamente esto puede comprobarse podría
ser verdadero o podría ser falso o quizá
nuestra prueba resulte poco concluyente
pero puede comprobarse se pueden
ejecutar simulaciones ver casos de
estudio de países en donde se haya hecho
esto y ver qué ocurrió con su economía
en comparación con las de otros países
que no hicieron esto así que aunque esto
parece una opinión de alguien que está a
favor de aumentar los impuestos a los
ricos en pro de la igualdad la
afirmación en sí misma no es normativa
la afirmación puede comprobarse y por lo
tanto es positiva un consejo para
distinguir mejor las afirmaciones
normativas es si dicen algo como
deberíamos hacer esto o aquello entonces
son afirmaciones normativas pero en este
caso la afirmación es comprobable el
siguiente enunciado es aumentar los
impuestos a los ricos disminuye el
crecimiento económico es una afirmación
normativa
o positiva nuevamente esto podría
parecer la opinión de alguien que está a
favor de que no se aumenten los
impuestos a los ricos pero la afirmación
en sí misma puede comprobarse ésta
también es una afirmación positiva
aunque sea algo opuesto a la afirmación
anterior ya que podemos comparar las
economías de países que han hecho esto
podríamos realizar simulaciones por
computadora para tratar de ver si está
afirmación es verdadera veamos un último
enunciado el gobierno debe aumentar los
impuestos a los ricos para pagar la
ayuda dirigida a los pobres es una
afirmación normativa o positiva en esta
situación la palabra debe así como las
palabras justo o injusto son una señal
de que se trata de una afirmación
normativa se trata de la opinión de
alguien y no es algo que podamos
comprobar si es verdadero o falso se
basa en creencias éticas y morales para
determinar si esto es cierto así que es
una afirmación normativa por lo que la
ponemos en la columna que le corresponde
en general podemos decir que las
afirmaciones normativas tratan
opiniones o de moral y que no pueden
comprobarse mientras que las
afirmaciones positivas sin importar si
estamos de acuerdo o en desacuerdo con
ellas pueden comprobarse y con esto
terminamos